Історична та прекрасна Мальта.
Утім, за цими фортецями та мурами криються конфлікти
та скандали, які практично розтерзують острів.
Журналіст-розслідувач Мануель Делія бореться
за спадщину Дафни Каруани Галіції,
яку вбили через журналістські розслідування
корупції в уряді.
Це суміш відповідальності та відчуття провини. Провина, бо ми лишили її наодинці.
Відповідальність, бо її роботу треба продовжувати.
Я відчуваю це так само, як і інші колеги.
Мені здається, уряд ніколи не був під таким тиском, як нині.
16 жовтня минулого року
автомобіль Дафни підірвали за кілька сотень метрів
від її будинку. Невдовзі після того
поліція схопила трьох дрібних злодіїв, які нині
чекають на суд у в’язниці.
Джонатан Ферріс працював слідчим у поліції.
Я вважаю, що ці три людини, ці троє чоловіків
не є замовниками вбивства.
Вони лише виконавці.
Утім, схоже, що розслідування вбивства
Дафни більше не є пріоритетом для уряду на чолі
з прем’єр-міністром Джозефом Мускатом.
Та й взагалі розслідування політичних скандалів
в країні має наслідки. Джонатана Ферріса звільнили
з відділу, в якому він розслідував відмивання грошей.
Відтоді йому погрожують.
Вони не хотіли, щоб моя команда копала глибше,
в жодному разі.
Мануель Делія прямує до банку "Пілатус".
Таємні оборудки та зв'язки фінансової установи
з мальтійськими урядовцями – це останнє,
що розслідувала Дафна Каруана Галіція.
Це банк із сотнею клієнтів, сотнею рахунків.
Багато з них належать відомим політичним діячам
Азербайджану, Анголи і навіть Мальти.
Але навіщо правлячій родині з Азербайджану банківський рахунок на Мальті?
Ймовірно, бо йдеться
про нелегальне відмивання грошей.
Низка скандалів і зрештою
вбивство журналістки шокували жителів Мальти.
Жіноча організація, що називає себе
"Occupy Justice", намагається
підтримувати іскру протесту.
Жінки  регулярно доглядають
за місцем загибелі Дафни.
Людину, журналістку вбили за речі, які вона знала та про які писала.
Якщо це не сигнал нам, що ми усі мусимо мовчати,
то я не знаю, що це. Але це неприйнятно,
вони не можуть відібрати у нас свободу слова.
Мануель живе в селі неподалік від столиці Валлетти.
Він знає, що на цьому маленькому острові –
не сховатися.
Мануель також відчуває атмосферу залякування.
Мафіозна країна – це держава, де інфраструктура та правлячі інституції
на службі у злочинності.
І саме це відбувається тут.
Невелика група людей сподівається,
що на Мальті відбудуться зміни.
Але потужні політичні сили працюють проти них. Образ Мальти як історичного та мальовничого острова оманливий.